俺はな
最近ようやく自分に何が足りないか分かってきて演技力が足りないんだよね方年ほど先
俺がやっぱこう
トップヒーローだとやっぱ方日本を代表するスーパースターになるためには便宜力が
必要だと思うんで
今日のツイッターでこのなんか演技の練習したいんでこうなんかシチュエーションを
教えてください
そのシチュエーションを俺が完璧にこなしますみなリコー zepp 者つべき
たとえつぶやきを変えたらいろんな方が高リップでこういうことをしてくださいみたい
なたくさんいただいたので乗車さん皆さんから教えてもらってそのシチュエーションは
もう僕がもう完璧な演技の練習だと思ったらかめりこますんで
行けお久しぶりに会った友達が自分の元カノ連れていた時は影シスター者マネージャー
ベティーとこありのままで歌っていたら後ろからお呼びでないのに名 j 本人が逃走
した時
はーいなぁママの芽寿
今先生に間違ったお母さんと言ってしまったとき
おかあ先生街に会って話してたらもれてしまった
やましたっ
あそこでさあ数死ぬまたこそ月から
久しぶりに帰郷したら両親がケンタウルスになっていた時いいんじゃないなぁ
いやー久しぶりに帰った
[音楽]
av を見ていてそれが幼なじみだったときいやいやいや早いながら
思いますいやーような
雪面白半分で友達のズボン下げたら全然知らない人だとかけ
しねえ
[拍手]
よねーする時を
んねあんっ
ああ
みゆきカラオケで熱唱しているときに店員さんが入ってきた時の反応
君がいた夏はというユーメイド姉母
開門ず飲んでいありがとうあそこにおいてください咳をしてきて花とれたべき
えっ
ああああああ
するっ
友達が落とし穴に落ちたと思ったらしたじゃなくて上にとって言った時の反応
すー
ん
持っています
エレベーターの扉に挟まれて北極に瞬間移動したといいます
[音楽]
だろぞ6
どういうこと
[音楽]
b
しています